welcome back to game time and as you've
heard we're all very excited that the
nba has returned to action
but there was a different kind of action
in the nation's capital today
unless you've been under a rock you're
fully aware of what happened
at the u.s capitol the thing i love
about the nba and its players and
coaches and
organizations is that they don't just
turn a blind eye to what's happening in
the world around them
exhibit a we saw it all in the bubble
down in orlando
well today jason tatum and jalen brown
together after they won the game
took some time to address what happened
earlier in the day let's listen
before we get started you know we
definitely want to speak to some of the
things that's been going on
in our society it reminds me of what dr
martin luther king has said
that there is two split different
americas and one america you get to
you get killed by sleeping in your car
selling cigarettes or playing in your
backyard
in another america you could just storm
the capital and
no tear gas no massive arrests no
none of that so i think it's obvious
it's 2021 i don't think anything has
changed
um we want to still acknowledge that we
want to still push for the change that
we're looking for
but as of yet we have not seen it we
want to continue to
keep conversations alive and do our part
all right we'll open it up for questions
we'll start with mark d'amico
hey guys obviously a difficult day for
everyone in america
and not the first time that you guys
have been put
in this situation with a basketball game
coming up when something
really important is going on in the
country
can you just take us through what the
situation was and what the circumstances
were behind closed doors and the
discussions and meetings that you guys
had
leading up to the game yeah just to
piggyback off what jb
said um it was heavy on our hearts you
know we was thinking about it
and unfortunately we continue to be in
the same situation
and uh you know we just you know had
open space in the locker room
to discuss these things whether we was
going to play or not
um similar to the bubble and like you
said it's 2021 and
we kind of continue to find ourselves in
the same situation and
it's tough because you know we're not
surprised by what we see on tv
um you know it's it's just it's the
world we live in
you know i just feel like you know the
same energy should be kept
as you know when you know we see our
people um
you know peacefully protesting for you
know
things that we see uh you know our
people getting
you know murdered on on tv and live
and and videos and you know they're
protesting the capital or riding the
capital
you know for losing an election you know
it's two different things and i want
the same energy on tv you know to be you
know their thugs
and criminals you know the same terms
that they use you know when they see our
people
you know protesting for losing our lives
and uh
you know i think it's bigger than
basketball is bigger than the game today
but i just felt like that
you know the statement us talking about
it us doing on the court on national tv
um could you know shed more light than
not playing and you know that's what we
talked about
gary washburn uh
for either you two guys or both
how do you manifest your anger into
something positive
because it's easy to be pissed you're
everybody you know we're all pissed as
black men
um given what's happened but how do you
kind of
manifest that and turn that into
something positive and productive
especially you guys are role models etc
um
how do you kind of do that that's tough
to be so young
and angry and justifiably angry but then
try to not let the anger body
or get to you it's definitely two sides
to a coin like
um basketball of course is our
profession and we're blessed to be in
this position
but we're also you know men we also our
fathers or
members of our community as well so when
they are we are
and we want to continue to be a voice
for the voiceless um but
you know sports is often used as a way
to lift people up it's a way to spread
joy
and uh that's the decision that we came
out here today with and hopefully we got
the win and we spread some joy today
jared weiss
you guys had these similar discussions
back in the bubble when the jacob bleach
uh blake shooting happens how did going
through that process before help
you come to your decision tonight and
also what made you guys want to come out
here together and speak
and stand together uh i think
you know just being unfortunately being
in a situation in a bubble and knowing
that
you know we had the the talks of you
know cancelling the whole bubble and
leaving
but realizing that you know as the nba
as players and house
the platform that we have on national tv
knowing that everyone's going to be
watching
um and be in front of a camera you know
we can play the game but you know when
we get asked questions we can
you know share light and talk about the
things that we want to express
and i think this is a great way it's
going to have to continue unfortunately
until we see real change
sherrod blakely
yeah uh this question is for both of you
but specifically for for you
jalen uh what we're talking about
happening at the capitol building what
we saw happen with the shooter of jacob
blake
and you contrast that with the elections
in
georgia and how those turned out and how
you guys played a role in
frankly moving people to be more engaged
in a civic
uh prospect of voting how do you
compartmentalize
all those different emotions obviously
the the joy of seeing more people
be participating in the voting process
but still the issues that you see happen
at the capitol building
and obviously jacob blake's a shooter
not being charged how do you
compartmentalize the emotions that all
those things
kind of bring about and create like
jason said it i don't think any of us
was really surprised
you know um that the ruling or or that
that what happened transpired today
i think that america is kind of built on
a lot of
racism that's the foundation and we
don't even flinch or shift at any of
those ideas so
um i think it was common sense for you
know for a lot of people
to be upset and things like that so all
of us felt the same way
you know but using this platform that we
have is important to us
we are role models we are members of our
community we do have people looking up
to us
and we want the next generation to know
where we stand you know we want the next
generation to know like
hopefully it's better than this one so
you want to continue to keep those
conversations alive
we don't we want to compartmentalize but
at the same time we want to voice our
opinions through the media
through our platforms through our
influence to let people know like
this is not okay it's people that have
lost their lives that we feel like
shouldn't have lost their lives
regardless of
the situation i think deadly force
should be the last result
in terms of handling you know an
equation or a problem
and and that's what we stand on i think
that
we seeing too many people on camera
losing their lives and we have to
explain that to our nieces our nephews
and it's hard looking at them and
telling them that it's going to change
and it's not so we want to just continue
to keep having those conversations
as athletes our responsibility is more
than just being a basketball player
we're not here to just entertain and
then go home like we are members of our
community
he's a member of st louis or duke or
whatever and you got people that's
watching and looking up so
let's try to use our platforms for good
and inspire some great change
how do you keep yourself inspired when
you see these things keep occurring
over and over and over again and you
guys take a position you take a stance
and when i say you i'm talking about
nba players in general and yet it seems
like
it's groundhog's day where we're seeing
a lot of the same things happen over and
over again how do you keep yourself
motivated and inspired
to keep pushing forward for the kind of
systemic change that you guys want
uh i think for me you know i just think
about our history
you know all the people that came before
us that you know sacrificed their lives
in
a much bigger way that you know myself
and him have opportunities to
to live out our dream and you know that
that doesn't go unnoticed
um and it should be talked about more so
i think we just have to carry that on in
in any way that we can like you said
we're role models
uh more than just basketball players and
um our platform is is huge and you know
it would be
um it'll be wrong if we didn't you know
take advantage of that um the
opportunities that we have
and you know just to speak for all those
people that don't have voices
um like we're doing to share the same
emotions and feelings um that we're
feeling
but we definitely want to express that
it's okay to be upset
it's okay to be angry i think that those
two get confused like we
expressed ourselves through you know
basketball today
winning the game but i mean i think
america has every right to be upset we
don't want to encourage violence
or anything of that nature but you know
we definitely are tired of seeing the
same things
over and over again so you know to feel
that that pain and that emotion
you know you can't control how that
necessarily
um is put out but um we want to continue
to use our platform
because we obviously you know want to
keep inspiring change you know and i
want to believe that
we're doing the right thing